the nearest available exit to the
chamber our assembly point will be in
the public car park at the side of the
Civic suite please do not delay or
evacuation to collect any four lines
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
counsel Stone please note that this
meeting is being audio recorded and also
remind you to make sure your co-founder
turned off and put on silent laugh now
please ask that the members be
upstanding to receive the chair
[Music]
good evening everyone
Isaac Newton said this if I have ever
made any valuable discoveries it has
been knowing more to patient attention
than to anything else Winston Churchill
said never give in never give in never
never never never if anything great or
small large or petty never give in
except of course to convictions of honor
and good sense malaria
said this it is a long road from
conception to completion I don't know
whether you've been watching the Winter
Olympics but Elsie Alexi Christie has
done entered the 500 for 1500 and a
thousand meter speed skating
competitions and has regrettably sadly
fallen at each hole and yet after her
final removal by disqualification of the
thousand meter she was interviewed and
she said I'll be back to Beijing in 2022
Charles Dickens said right on right on
roughshod if need be smooth short if
that will do but ride on ride over if
necessary any form of obstacle to win
the race in the book of Hebrews Paul the
Apostle encouraged the Christians of the
church to pursue with perseverance to
encourage to spur on and in the
difficulties of chamber you are
encouraged to spur each other on
with your guts in perseverance let us
pray
father God we come once more in this
place and and we think of perseverance
in all its different ways shapes and
forms we see the example of you
persevering through atrocities and
conflict and those same principles are
present in everyday life to persevere be
with the conversations this evening in
the perseverance that is needed here in
this place in the name of Christ our
name
what is reference and we received
produce the counselor open counselor
Melton and counsel of real and other any
others item two minutes of the meeting
held on the 12th December 2017 and the
extraordinary meeting held on the 13th
of February 2018
are there three members item three
declarations weakness are there any item
for an absence from the chairman leader
I had paid service I think at this stage
actually by Roger ups and Pam from the
Gideons
thank you once again it is my pleasure
to be here and make this presentation
until chairman once that part about it
is for the suit the second successive
year I'm actually only here in blue
capacity as a substitute one of our
members carrier Evans who was in last
year still very poorly at the moment we
can't carry out this task I expect most
of you know now because we do this every
year
you know something about the Gideons
that we've been putting Bibles into
hotels and many other places as well
my wife and I mostly engaged the schools
thing you like to do with the schools
it's just a very great idea of the
pupils of why we do this just in a few
sentences now perhaps I can explain it
to you we took a few apples about going
back our journey and the fact that when
you bring on a cartoon any you need
direction so that journey if it's
somewhere you've never been on before
I'm gonna point out to them there's
another journey of all of us are on we
call it the journey of life it's so easy
to go wrong or that journey take a wrong
turn or two in Gideon's a very simply
when Christian people who believe that
there is a God and that he speaks to us
through this book so it is the perfect
blind on the journey to mind when we do
see light are completely changed we can
test remembers there have been occasions
with ourselves where somebody has
actually bought into a hotel
so distress they perform their intention
of committing suicide with the scene a
copy of the Bible picked it up and their
lives are going to change me in a
similar way in prisons to the
testimonies of prisoners who have seen
the popular so testament wheeling and
they to starting read and their lives
have been transformed they completely
changed and so the same thing we believe
it is the perfect guide to this journey
of life to this journey and in the
descriptions that we put we do include a
verse from the Bible very much along
this theme it's from the longest psalm
psalm 119 which says your word is a lamp
to my feet and a light for my path
there's no madam chairman on behalf of
the Gideons again surfaces on this
journey of life for everyone else
[Applause]
receiving a little company moving in or
was it see it's going I wasn't saying
how many years ago that was but I did
carry that around with me many many we
really got vote on it but I'm going to
try to come
so everything I've been doing recently
but one of the highlights of the last
couple of months is I was fortunate
enough together with our managing
director and vice chairman to welcome
our Prince Edward so we had a royal
visit King in our district and I think
this is a personal visit we've had for
many years and he was visiting an
Excalibur screw bolts limited in Hockley
third one the a second Queen's Award for
innovation so that was a really
memorable day and another memorable day
was the Holocaust Memorial Day of course
which I've a few of you did attend so
say the lots of other events but there
were two that stand out very much in a
scuffle on i-25 not be questions and
then questions on notice there are no
item six
this is from the last council meeting
there is none minutes of effective
including meetings held between the
periods the secondly December 2017 and
the 9th of February 2018 as listed are
they no item 8 to consider any reports
with the executive and commutative
Council there are none item 9 report on
urgent decisions there are none and
actual 10 report of the leader of the
work of the executive thank you very
much this is the fourth ordinary Council
80 of the 2017 18 units per year but I
would like to welcome in the members
since the meeting on the 12th of
December the executive has met once
during which considerations including
the quarter 3 2017 18 financial
management of the Queen's report the
progress made by leaders and chief
executives come strategically shaping is
preparation of a South physics 20 2015
but the message that my colleagues and I
on the executive of dealt with include
accepting the brownfield register of
potential ground for planning sites
within the district into the council's
evidence base and publishing it to the
councilors website also acknowledging
the need for a memory of an
understanding for the Essex coast
recreational avoidance and mitigation
strategy as an effective means to
discharge the countless duty to
cooperate responsibilities with other
assets councils and Natural England in
relation to this specific strategic and
cross-boundary matter and delegating
authority to the assistant director
planning a regeneration so that is
design the memorandum ensure that it is
discharged as an operational level
that's always chairman I would be happy
to take any questions from members in
respective work
tested much for my tactically we have
introduced perfectly thank you
thank you item I control setting account
detects 2018-19 but chairman of thruyou
countless members of the public the
press this is my 14th budget as leader
of the Conservative administration the
budget pressures under which local
government operates have intensified and
this will Authority sixth continues to
look closely at opportunities for
savings and most importantly at how we
can increase revenue this is not only
respects response to cuts in that way to
growth and spending power but also as a
significant cost increases arising from
demographic pressures local government
has faced an unprecedented period of
funding pressures since 2010 and this
looks set to continue at least for the
medium term with central government
placing increasing emphasis on local
authorities to raise revenues locally
rather than relying on graphene cut
rocks for District Council will lose all
of its revenue support from funding in
2018 19 that's a reduction of 1.2
billion since 2015-16 and faces a
potential financial clip it in 2019 20
with the proposed implementation of
negative rates as well which could
reduce the councillors funding by
further six hundred thousand per annum
this is coupled with considerable
financial pressures in particularly
increased demand for services new
structure jury Duty's for homelessness
and rising inflation which together give
rise to projected gap of around 1.8
million
20 22 23 Rockford District Council has
already taken significant steps to start
by pressing this projected gap through
identification of proposals including
efficiencies savings and new income
streams which will help you to continue
the journey towards financial self
sustainability in the Lincoln Tunnel
looking into the future we have a
business plan that sets the high level
priorities that the council work towards
in the next couple of years
it's themes give the focus on capital
investment and provide a clear direction
to achieve a better use for council
resources to deliver priorities our
priorities are to become financially
self-sufficient to use early
intervention to manage demand on our
services to maximize their assets and
enable communities despite the
challenges faced we have continued to
deliver excellent services to our
residents our achievements over the past
year included launching a new web chat
service on the council website to make
it easier and quicker to contact the
counselor as normal office hours and a
new Twitter account for Public Health so
that our followers will have the most
up-to-date news on anything to do with
public health our 14th annual Wildwood
study which took place on the 3rd of
June epoxy woods have attracted over
4,000 visitors who had a chance to try
they had activities including
axe-throwing bushcraft and 10 building
focusing a landlord forum in partnership
with South in DeCarlo Point Borough
Council's continuing to provide local
businesses with advice and support
including close the posting of business
breakfast a program of 1 day of enter
the students across our secondary
schools providing an insight into the
business world the focus is on the
employment sectors where there is an
evidence skills gap supporting students
to gain employment and businesses to
access individuals with the relevant
skill set awarding grants totaling
50,000 pounds to a range of community
initiatives around the district
launching a safe at home graft
support local residents living in their
home with the dementia diagnosis being
second in the county
no country fit that right secondly the
country has been more than the treatment
of grateful to my colleague here we hit
news a responsible for this after more
than 350 authorities recycling with a
recycling rate of sixty three point nine
percent I think that's something we
should be proud of and so should our
residents investing three hundred and
thirty thousand pounds in before I've
never said ravaging
refurbishing three of the district's
public conveniences so that people
continue to have a good stand of the
facilities whilst they're out and about
being able read community safety a
critical predication scheme powers by
Essex Police which gives employees or
the council targeted police powers to
help tackle anti-social issues as a
council with the history of prudent
financial management we will continue to
look at areas where their costs can be
further reduced or additional income
generated however in 2018-19 there is a
need to increase council tax by two
point nine by nine percent review helps
on the huge financial pressures the
district is facing this equates to an
increase of 12 people week four AB and E
property the proposal to set the
Rockford districts plan D council tax
for 2018-19 223 pounds sixty five
minutes per year
the breakdown of the total effect
accounts for tax for AB and E property
and 2018-19 will be Essex County Council
1143 pounds and Ivan's Essex County
Council social care there will be
seventy eight thousand sixty six pence
police and crime Commissioner for Essex
hundred and sixty nine pounds and two
pens Essex fire authorities seventy
pounds and thirty eight pins the air for
each town and parish council forty five
pounds of nine
and all sorts for district council
223,000 65 minutes so the total area
Chancellor tax for bandy property to
2018-19
would be one thousand seven hundred and
thirty pounds and 71 pence an increase
of 79 pounds 37 since 2017 18 in
conclusion although these are still
difficult financial times oxford
district council remains committed to
providing excellent services to its
residents farms but this in mind we'll
be doing all we can to deliver
innovative and high quality services
chairman i recommended the Rochford
district council tax remembers approval
and i so move the other items once again
thank you chairman Charlie the seconder
thank you
Thank You June you're not going to take
very long I'd like you to turn members
to the rootball item 12 we've already
heard the precepts and council taxes go
up by seventy nine thirty seventh of the
year and that will cause some residents
I think we also ought to reflect upon
the fact that that represents an
increase of 4.8% in case you hadn't
noticed CP on it it is the way the
government through the appropriate
office or responsibilities quote CPI of
2.7 so all of the councils and all of
the other services that praise precepts
considerably higher than the rate of
inflation and that in itself I think is
a problem and it's going to be the
problem even more as the government
government releases cats on precepts and
council taxes in various ways I think
it's time the government actually
recognize that and put some sort of
collective cap upon all of the
contributors to the final council tax
with this council correct
I can't look for item five because I'm
already voted against the council tax
increase
this counselors two point nine eight I'm
not going to ask you chains to take item
five out
I can't votes hopefully against all of
the items three one to ten scientist me
thank you gentlemen
listen to our counselor Mason says of
the reality is were not in a position
between women's what are their
authorities centers their announcement
facts we have the unfortunate duty of
having to collect it for them not the
duty that we are we always enjoy because
we do get tarred with other people's
decisions at times but the reality is
the increase for Rockford District
Council of government in to speak today
I to the same on the notice wit 535
events the 2.18 percent increasing I
just went over we won't own cancellous
this that in fact this and council do
impose tax rises or other councils may
be post tax rises or parish councils or
transferring the public conveniences to
do them so by the fact that they we are
no longer eyes and Council funding those
two toilets you lose the priests it
increased to parish councils and those
councils ugly viewpoint the factory
priests their preceptor above inflation
versus [ __ ] worth their thank you
thank you madam chairman I'd like to
echo the comments should be made by
amazing in relation to those those
issues being a member of one of the
parish councils I'm aware of the
arguments and the discussions that went
on a parish in relation to sit in
presets for that parish and Matt refer
have been taken into consideration
taking over public toilets with all this
new consideration in there in our budget
considerations so it has a very the
other batteries I understand special
saying in relation to other local
authority just we don't have any control
over how they say and they're simply
irrelevant at the council tax but I
would like to point out that tenant area
increase is above inflation so it is
over what people are normally expecting
to to get in there and their own wages
that they might expect increases in
their waiting so we are asking more of
them perhaps what they might be getting
in their income and I think that we have
to bear that in mind when we are
I also voted against the increase for
therefore role will be for you or with
my other colleagues in Spain on this
matter
councilor sparing Thank You Jo
I put the comments regarding offloading
expenses regarding public toilets to the
parishes well just point out the
perishing towns it was entirely their
decision whether they took on these
responsibilities it was not a - today
were given to continues facility and to
the parishes that are involved in this
have not increased their preceptor -
thank you just one point chairman and
I'll make a declaration as an issue
county councillor part of the increase
of course is for social care and I think
everybody wants to make sure that we
have the right social care aspects for
all of us as we all get older so it's
quite happy to pay that extra money
coming forward for the social care
aspects of the Essex County Council
precept and I want to see that reduced
at all so you know from that point of
view chairman I'm pleased it's going you
know I think it will be well used in
various going and I think that applies
to most of the councils including the
police we have one of the lowest
precepts for the police service in the
country which is why we're seeing a
slightly larger increase and where it's
actually seeing benefits from paying
that to buy that the numbers of puppies
are the pea so I think there are aspects
that you need to consider when you're
looking at some of these increases which
go above actual inflation which is just
a crude measure of children Thank You
councillor mr. Mason thank you however
critical inflation is it might be those
are the ones that deter me a very great
deal of phonetic
in this country and actually probably
disowned it in all other countries
including Europe even though believe
I've got to say that my point in making
that the total of all of the increases
was 4.8% was the point out that it is
above the rate of inflation which is
usually the sort of measure that people
use in terms of rewarding pay raises and
all those sorts of things so there will
be people Eve the government should be
looking at this because we should be
prioritizing where we make our increases
the issue is I don't disagree with
increasing an amount of funding for
Social Care it may be in not so many
years actually looking to actually have
some benefit but from that like many
others were here but the reality is the
Rockford district council didn't have to
raise its preset above 1.5 percent it's
about time the government looked at
these caps and realize what's happening
thank you
so can I have sharp hands for those
thoughts or to be 10 recommendations
thank you that's courage that woke up
the site in place alternate master
everybody voted against Karen okay stay
on the bike as I all right sorry about
that then I took the got it felt for so
and abstaining
item searching for the pay policy
statement
thank you just very briefly and members
will be aware that the policy is
required to be proved by through pencil
and every year there are actually new
changes to bring to members attention in
relation to this version of the pay
policy and really terminals for a menace
to agree thank you questions move the
recommendation changes are seconded
Thank You counselor so any questions
that great memories
the client reaching and at eight o'clock
[Music]